[Music]
and make it rain news precipitation I
you made it rain though I went like this
office invitation physical rain we're
thinking the same because I was okay
thank you man I wish that was so it's
it's real life right now I went to the
strip club and then when I got a hundred
dollars in ones they give it to you like
in a stack like this and you feel really
rich sure make it pain literally yeah
but there's no paper inside is just whoo
that that's our prop money submitted by
it can you roll your R's who cares a lot
of people Joe you guys do it you can you
do it oh you said my Spanish
pronunciation is awesome a single cream
person they can't roll our eyes no
couldn't sit in our alley
I don't think there's a lot of people
who can't roll their eyes right there's
a lot we've all okay you know they can't
my joke can't there you go let's see you
look ahead at all
rich people may soon be able to buy fake
meteor showers on demand what they can
buy anything on demand oh really about
come on uh don't they can't you buy like
scarf babies on demand I'll [ __ ] sell
them fake meteors show what does that
mean on demand educate me give me
$100,000 and then I get glitter and I
sprinkle it it's when you want it onda
me so does it shoot through the air yeah
thank you actually see a meteor shower
when I want it once you can just say I
want to see one now and then they fake
it I mean it looks like a real meteor
shower so okay there's a new company
that they they have the satellites about
220 miles up in the sky yes you've done
other satellites it just starts to
[ __ ] go down and then that's the
meteor that you're seeing there's a
North Korean company now they kick out
about 15 to 20 small pebbles on command
while it's all over the city that you
pay for and it just looks like a meteor
shower
doesn't it hit people or does it or does
it burn off like a real meteor
mid-flight before it does burn off
imagine you're like that house that
keeps getting sprayed right what the
[ __ ] stop ordering meteor showers yeah
sucks I thought it was gonna be people
in like a sequence bodysuit doing
cartwheels around you that is amazing so
how does it go so I buy yeah you get
five dollars and then in two people go
back back and forth doing cartwheels
while you watch them I think your meteor
shower your business really quick cuz
five dollars for such a service that's
not explicit but 5 dollars five dollars
I'm not gonna go out of service I'm just
gonna get homeless people how much does
that cost though for somebody to order a
meteor shower on demand so they did say
that major cities that use fireworks for
celebrating events they are really
really really expensive but this company
is saying that they won't be as
expensive as fireworks they don't want
to tell you and you know what happens
when you go to a restaurant and there's
no [ __ ] prices on that menu the
market price scurry yes true
so fireworks across like 25k per event
so if it's less than 25 K well are we
like 15 how do you know that how do you
have this firework [ __ ] experience I
feel like I read this somewhere but if
that was just me taking in guests oh
that's how did you guess that's $25,000
I know Disneyland talks about it how
much they every night they blow off the
fireworks it's like a [ __ ] gazillion
dollars well not that much but like it's
a hundred grand four hundred thousand
like it's a lot this is a good they're
saying in this article here that Tokyo's
firework display run about forty
thousand a firework Oh Jo Tokyo these
people have waited new york's fourth of
July okay it's about six million
oh [ __ ] yeah I like look up Disneyland's
cuz it's so much that I was mind blowing
that every [ __ ] night when they shoot
off those fireworks they burned that
much money I'm not that surprised it
cost like a hundred and like fifty bucks
just to get in it does any people that
go everyday so they make a median it's
anywhere between Isis at the Magic
Kingdom forty-one thousand fifty five
thousand a night
then the rich people would get by 2025
like 25,000 right since it's like lower
a different tier than that yeah that's a
lot of money like because they're trying
to do the first one for the Tokyo
Olympics so oh there's gonna be a meteor
shower at the Tokyo Olympics so there's
gonna be a bunch of Japanese people
getting sprayed with this [ __ ]
artificial rock [ __ ] but see this is
what's gonna happen if they're doing
that for the Tokyo Olympics that's gonna
be whack as [ __ ] [ __ ] you realize
that right
one each me son sound of a meteor show
this don't know yeah that's it I like
this no no that sounded oh oh you know
why it's in Japan so it's oh yeah this
hold on I was thinking of fireworks
exactly there's no noise I said $25,000
because I was thinking firework you know
what I want to add a riot in Tokyo
Disneyland and then everyone was like
this though there's so much highlighter
we'll just wow you were the only loud
obnoxious Americans going would know
because they're very reserved and yeah
I'm scared of roller coasters but I was
so [ __ ] distracted I was like they
were smiling they were just like there's
just no noise no there's quite the time
the party on the inside that's that's
bizarre to me you know well so some
experts here they're saying that that's
a bad idea having a satellite because
there's about 40 satellites as of right
now that are at that height or 200
action to each other yeah well shooting
[ __ ] meteors those pebbles yeah
they're shooting into it so the company
went back and said well we're gonna have
a very advanced system and we could see
where all these other 40 satellites are
and we'll make sure that we will not be
releasing anything if they're within
like 120 miles distance but then they
were saying well we don't have access to
every single satellite information
that's in the sky or in the space right
now because there's also like secret
yeah so much is top secret ninja shoot
them down or not and there's
they won't pop off any meters yeah but
then they're saying like why is that
worth Popeyes so funny this is like rich
people conversation that I can't even be
a party
yeah United means so I just don't care
it's like well actually if your if your
satellite touches my satellite but [ __ ]
I don't know what this feels like
yeah you know you could control the
Bellagio water show you can't
yeah that sounds more fun to me yeah but
each time that water show goes up it's
10 grand oh [ __ ]
so every time so hundred twenty four
thousand dollars they give you a button
that's it just a planet yeah you get out
you get a red button and you slam that
[ __ ] man it golden dollars get in the
water Bulls up and [ __ ] in this ten
grand
Wow oh yeah you pay 10 grand to be able
to push the button that makes it go up
yet oh what a cool propose wait how many
buttons is it though do you control the
water salt no Dobby dogs just want to
activate it you're like the bloomin crew
of water well you could keep doing it
over and over and over
yeah what it's like 10 grand 10 grand
never become a billionaire dude that's
exactly what I would do that is my dream
no it's not the pirate ships your dream
don't you have a lot of dreams
ok fine [ __ ] I have a lot of dreams
I don't just sleep once I sleep a lot
you know what's [ __ ] up the Treasure
Island show they don't do the pirate
theme nor all the new tea everyone's
trying to be all alligators [ __ ] the
[ __ ] is wrong with them it's not it's
called Ti I've never even seen it what
yeah yeah you did we we that's my
restaurant I've got a pirate ship you're
not memorable enough wait wait but there
was no show no exactly we don't have the
show but they do have the ship cuz they
don't do the show that's why I don't
remember it cuz there was no show I was
specific I do she completely forgot
about you - that's exactly but I don't
remember their Beach you used to be able
to walk the strip and see the shot Jack
Sparrow yeah
or a different song oh that's what it
felt like they started making it like
all ladies and news kind of [ __ ] and
I'm like why are you doing [ __ ]
pirates man Vegas because they need more
people yeah and then it got weird and
they got desperate [ __ ] like they're
just ripped fishnets everywhere mm-hmm
yeah pretty weird it was like it used to
be just pirates I don't know I miss the
Vegas where it was like which are you
booing all these naked ladies boo
put some clothes on or yeah I'm like
you're not a real pirate no real went I
know yeah where's your scurvy see the
yellow and orange skin no honestly man
if I had the money and if they actually
go through this through with this I
would be so down a paper oh yeah but
they're hitting other satellites just
[ __ ] rich people's entertainment [ __ ]
rich people but I do want to be right
here just like we all do
rich people I become until I become one
yeah then I want it but a meteor shower
is not the same as a real meteor shower
yeah I would pay for is the [ __ ]
Aurora what does that call the aurora
borealis yeah yeah I mean you all right
sorry guys but yeah that's why we are
idiot go ahead take your next to see and
put on those orange glasses because
that's the same what the [ __ ] you
know shooting stars isn't the same thing
as a shooting star is an immediate
shower the shooting star part I don't
know it is that's a meteor so they're
shooting multiple shooting stars is it
different
no shooting stars a dead [ __ ] sucks
see I would think that a shooting star
shooting stars on a dead son it's not a
dead it's a diet or some [ __ ] now or
something wrong I don't know [ __ ] about
education I know what it is go ahead no
go ahead it's a piece of rock that's
flying from outer space a piece of rock
yeah and then it's it's burning off into
our atmosphere yeah that's a meteor
shower I think if one is singular and
one is multiple okay that's all this let
me see I know we have the [ __ ]
knowledge no no I refuse don't you
google that [ __ ] up
don't you dare [ __ ] your prove me wrong
yeah it's the whole hitting that
atmosphere and then like yeah it's not
so Jess I don't give a [ __ ] about that
[ __ ] useless knowledge I don't know
nothing about stars my pirate yeah oh
it's gonna be so there's gonna be I want
to recreate the old like 1415 century
the curb it Carribean era I want to have
like ships of different countries and
we'll get like criminals of different
countries like England France and Spain
and it will make them fight each other
on the ship
yeah like but they they have to use old
weapons like the ship where it launches
that what does that thing called Canada
Canada yeah yeah and then we'll have
like um everyone dressed up in like
those Napoleon outfits you know like
those I think gonna all be short like
that era - oh I never even thought about
that that'll be super historical ly
accurate what bar my tongue that
[Music]